Zachary where's the
remote Oh What A Catch by dck Wilson
just turn the TV on every off season
after losing the NFC Championship Game
coach likes to spend time at the beach
with his expensive offensive weapons woo
who needs a QB we're all loaded maybe I
can have a catch sorry kid I'm not ready
to commit to the whole franchise QB
thing to them I was irrelevant but this
summer something changed hey
guys wa Ro got hot old
Shante okay this looks really good oh
grow up Zack it'sing fairy
tale don't you see you're the guy Brock
I dumped try for you but you gave up so
much for him like you did embarrassing
things to pursue him
and is
anive pop song change it Aaron I have a
whole team I need to give attention to
something else okay so we pretend you're
an elite QB to make my ex jealous I'm
not
jealous maybe you are an elite
quarterback no no it's too soon anything
else dog Peterson was hoping to go all
the way this year and he knew just the
partner wow maybe there is hope for
these young kids after all no being
young is bad it is scary and it is
confusing
[Music]
look leedale is under attack shots shots
explosions too much plot I need help
sorry F that's like a Do's job oh hell
yeah this is so terrible I love
it who am I I'm the guy who watched Gold
Member a thousand times who are
you Nathaniel hackit
is
the